but that guy right there adam wainwright
old uncle charlie well he can fix things
for you in a hurry so excited to watch
him go out to work the left-handed
banner is
adam frazier
and the old uncle charlie is delivered
into right field for adam frazier
who was three for four with a home run
on thursday 3-2 pitch they start the
runner they'll avoid the double play
coming in a step or two tommy edmond
[Applause]
polanco a ground ball edmond from the
outfield grass the pirates will strand a
runner j.t brubaker's numbers strikeout
per inning and he's only walked 15 on
the year
and he missed on the inside corner and
the lead off walk
goldie one for seven against this
right-hander
and the o2 is hit up the middle for a
base hit
carlson will stop at
second base and a single for goldschmidt
on an o2 pitch
and a big punch out the slider from
brubacher molina two for four against
this right-hander yachty base head into
right
dylan carlson coming home throw by
polanco up the line yadi delivers
with a two out rbi single here in the
bottom of the first and it's one nothing
st louis
there's fraser
and that does it so the walk to carlson
hurts you know this you gave adam
wainwright a lead he's going to go out
there and attack trying to get as quick
of an inning as possible here
and a swing and a mess you're going to
get a strikeout this about as quick as
you're going to get it in three pitches
here the good cutter he throws right off
the plate away it starts away it stays
away
so one out base runner here's eric
gonzalez
and reaches out and gets it down nice a
b there from gonzales
he wasn't gonna be denied
first and second with one out
and a shot
to second knock down there's one not in
time for two
there it is he did get something
little tailing action a little sink
pitching backwards there you go sorry
about it learn kid second strikeout both
coming in that inning
but he has only one home run since
coming back from the injured list
that is hammered out to deep left at the
wall
gone
bounced around in big mac land
then it dropped down
and a long one off the bed of paul
deyoung
his ninth home run of the year
two to nothing st louis
and there's fastball strike three call
that's the second out
fastball out over the plate up and hit
to center caught by reynolds
and you can dust your hands of the
cardinals in the second but paul deyoung
hits one out
swung on and lofted out to deep center
field reynolds back on it to the warning
track now turns around to the wall
did he make the catch yes he did but i
never saw the ball in his glass
wow the dead ball carry i mean he
thought he was going to catch it before
he got to the track but it just kept
going and going so one out and nobody on
and a full count on nolan ornato
arenado sends it into the gap in right
center field
drops in for a hit
on his way to second standing up with
another double
[Applause]
to right field polanco is there
and cardinal strand two they lead
by two polanco looking to reach here
hitting cleanup
hits this hard to right and a line drive
home run clear the deck
grab yourself a cup of coffee and get on
the board that's number eight
for polanco it's 2-1
but i mean off the bat
i'm like okay that's a double and then
wham it hits the back of a seat pow
here's the 1-2 pitch a swing and a miss
he got him with a curveball at 74 miles
an hour
he struck him out looking back-to-back
case in five today
two hops hit to short and a high throw
but goldie down on the bag
the one-two pitch
swang and a miss strikeout number six
oh wow
stabbed at it and what a play there by
paul de young
tricky hop for him we're midway through
five
here's paul goldschmidt singled on a no
two pitch to center in the first inning
and goldie hits a high fly ball into
deep right center
way out of here
that is one of the longest home runs to
center this year
goldie a bomb
and it adds to the saint louis lead it's
3-1
colin moran now
and there's a line drive
face hit even though he's only given up
one run on four hits it seems like he's
got a lot of a lot of pitches thrown
and now to left and no he can't hold on
it's first and second
o'neill
not able to hold on
the pool count delivery swing and a miss
he struck him out
the one-two pitch and he struck him out
eight today for wainwright
and the 2-1 is popped up
who wants it here
carlson has it
wayne wright out of the jam now
wainwright tries to go through seven
he'll be done after this if he gets
through
as part of the order
gonzales and gonzalez gonna start things
off with a base hit
second hit of the day
and this may be it for adam wainwright
and he is going to get a monster ovation
again
three-two pitch
hayes chops it towards third arenado to
pop and gets the lead man what a play by
nolan orinato that was not easy little
top spin tricky hop and gets a lead man
ground ball sharply hit de young the
turn the double play
a 3-2 pitch
inside and deyoung another walk
so on base for the second time runner
goes that's the young throw down to
second
and the ball scoots away and a stolen
base for paul de young
and a good chase that's where perez
wanted it stratton delivered
with the slider but walked him so
nolan arnado will come up with runners
at first and second
and pops it up
stratton
works hard to
put a zero up there
the one-two pitch
struck him out
moran now lines one towards center field
and that is carrying over the head of
carlson
that's the place to hit the ball today
center field
a double and he's aboard for reynolds
full count delivery gallegos
swaying and a miss held on to by molina
comes back to get him in the strikeout
his second in this inning the 1-1 pitch
popped up left side
coronado
oh he caught it
in fair territory
back to the enfield nolan oronato
reyes has converted 19 straight saves to
begin his career and the o2 pitch
gammel
pops it up shinning from the sun tommy
edmond
newt park calls him off and the first
out
back to reyes and this will be on number
two
ground ball orinato across the diamond
the losing skid that thankfully is over
for the cardinals
a one two three for reyes and they take
game three by the final of three to one